After all, to make the real thing, you say the real material, but
you can see it by seeing it.
[Music]
ni
My name is
Hiroshi Sasaki.
[Music]
So I've been moving to specialize in the wind for about 45 years now
. I think it takes at least 10 years to make a real taste.
[Music] It's
good to rub a scalpel.
There is also a house for female musicians who
do skateboarding, so the reason why you shouldn't be a labor demon god is a carnivorous transparent music that is mixed with
you.  But
there is no bra that is kind to put in the mouth. In
the case of a couple, hitting with comprehensive art is already outstanding if you use a wonderful one.
I think it's a symbiosis to take care of people's lives, but it's absolutely safe.
You can see that by seeing it made
ni
me.